[Musique]
nous sommes au siège de numerix
entreprise spécialisée dans la
transformation digitale est situé à
montigny le bretonneux
parmi ces activités il ya la cyber
sécurité et dernières technologies
développées imparfait pour lutter contre
les attaques informatiques
pour en parler nous sommes avec un
maître bouaziz bonjour bonjour et
bienvenue chez nous
merci de nous recevoir et donc vous êtes
le responsable de la recherche et du
développement est-ce que vous pouvez
nous parler de ce pare-feu donc ce
firewall alors nous travaillerons
s'appelle dms estevan dms pour dire
double masque c'est une nouvelle
technologie qui a été breveté de
filtrage des règles sur les firewall
aujourd'hui et donc nous utilisons cette
innovation cette nouvelle technologie
pour permettre plus de performances plus
de stabilité plus de sécurisation sur
les équipements informatiques en gros
l'idée c'est d'éviter toute attaque
informatique comment ça fonctionne
concrètement sur un ordinateur
aujourd'hui nous avons accès depuis une
interface web sur l'ensemble des modèles
et outils d'administration
de notre feuille rôle donc nous avons un
tableau de bord globale qui nous permet
de voir l'utilisation les taux de
saturation de stockage et de ressources
globalement sur notre freeroll on a
aussi la possibilité de gérer plusieurs
typologies d'interface réseau donc avec
plusieurs types de configurations et
c'est ces configurations là nous
permettent derrière d'éditer des règles
de filtrage qui vont être traitées avec
notre filtre à jp à double masque pour
permettre aux plus de performances comme
nous pouvons le voir ici nous avons
l'option fils tripp et à double masque
qui nous permet donc
fils tripp et à double masque qui nous
permet de voir des gains réels par
rapport aux failles rôle classique donc
ses gains de performances peuvent
atteindre les 90% aujourd'hui merci
ahmed bouazzi ce pour ses explications
merci à vous et on va rejoindre tout de
suite ahmed aboul hadid qui va nous
expliquer que le numérique s'est engagé
aussi dans d'autres offres concernant la
cybersécurité et parmi les autres offres
dans la cyber pour numérique s'il ya
aussi des formations et numérique s'est
engagé est partie prenante du campus
cyber qui ouvrira en janvier 2022 à la
défense et pour en parler nous sommes
avec ahmed aboul a dit le bonjour
bonjour
le responsable cybersécurité chez
numerix alors est-ce que vous pouvez
nous expliquer en quoi vous êtes partie
prenante du projet de ce campus il a
alors tout à fait donc numérique ça a
souhaité intégrer et rejoindre justement
le campus cyber le combustible r c'est
une volonté donc qui avait piloté et
j'irai mis en place par là par la
présidence donc le président a décidé de
mettre une souveraineté au niveau de la
cyber sécurité sur le territoire
français et numérique s'est impliqué
justement a souhaité rejoindre sète ce
projet là concrètement vous allez faire
quoi concrètement numériques seront
rejoints cette organisation pour pouvoir
participer au développement être un des
acteurs dans le monde de la
cybersécurité en france et participer à
des ateliers de la recherche et
d'innovation autour de la cybersécurité
numéris aujourd'hui fait quoi dans
l'information en cyber sécurité
numérique c'est a décidé depuis
plusieurs années d'investir sur la
formation que ce soit pour les clients
ou pour les collaborateurs ces
formations sont orientés dans la cyber
sécurité sur tout ce qui est la gestion
la vulnérabilité la montée en
compétences aujourd'hui sur les enjeux
de la sécurisation des infrastructures
et des réseaux merci ahmed aboul adil
responsable cybersécurité chez numerix
merci
depuis sa création en 2012 numerix
accompagne les entreprises dans leur
transformation digitale
160 collaborateurs engagés au quotidien
près de 8 millions d'euros de chiffre
d'affaires par an pour en parler nous
sommes avec son pdg
mon des rails a dit bonjour bonjour
qu'est ce que vous pensez de l'évolution
de votre société écoutez donc
effectivement depuis 2012 là aujourd'hui
donc on arrive effectivement donc on
devient donc une sorte de pme ou grosses
pme déjà établi à l'international
aujourd'hui numériques ses actifs bien
entendu sur la fonction dans son digital
donc c'est avec quatre corps de métiers
qui sont là dit la transformation
digitale qui sont la cybersécurité
qu'ils sont effectivement la recherche
et développement et aussi numérique
university qu'un organisme de formation
spécialisés dans la cybersécurité dans
le management et dans les technologies
microsoft est aussi open source on l'a
vu vous développez vos solutions en
cybersécurité avec le fireball vous
proposer des formations mais le corps de
votre métier c'est aussi d'envoyer des
consultants dans les entreprises et ça
m'a écouté le corps de notre métier
c'est le service à proprement dit dans
le service aujourd'hui se transforme et
ceux effectivement se met en place selon
trois niveaux donc on a affecté moi bien
entendu donc le haut conseil et c'est
notre expert effectivement qu'il va
travailler chez nos clients nos clients
dans le secteur automobile que notamment
notamment renault notamment le groupe
bastide en tice dans ce secteur banque
assurance dans le secteur public mais
aussi dans le secteur du telecom donc
aujourd'hui donc ça c'est effectivement
notre expertise là où elle va
actuellement essentiellement dans la
région parisienne mais aussi sur la
france le deuxième positionnement donc
c'est c'est le forfait c'est à partir du
moment qu'on s'engage sur des résultats
par rapport à effectivement dans 41 ma
technique bien défini et le troisième
niveau a2 service c'est la tm la tierce
maintenance applicative c'est à partir
du monde comprend des projets et on
assure la maintenance corrective et
évolutive
qu'elle comptait telle évolution dans
les prochaines années chez numérique bah
écoutez je pense que là à la crise
trouver d'être passé par là on a
effectivement donc atteint et atteindre
une certaine résilience par rapport aux
activités donc on a gardé on va dire le
chiffre d'affaires 2010 9 g activement
donc on a fait le même en 2020 et pour
nous c'est un exploit là on repart à la
croissance donc avec 15% et prévision de
15 % de croissance sur l'année 2021
aujourd'hui on est déjà à
l'international donc on a déjà attaqué
le continent africain avec un hub vient
délivrer center qui existe en tunisie et
nous on suit donc l'afrique
sub-saharienne pour nous donc c'est
important pour la suite de notre
positionnement notre notre vocation
internationale auquel est aussi
européenne bien entendu effectivement
donc considérable de plus en plus de
france et bien entendu donc on va y
arriver effectivement dans qu'à des
niveaux de croissance qui sont au moins
égale par rapport à ce qu'on a fait
entre 2010 et 2018 et 2018 2019 merci
mon dernier a dit merci beaucoup p dg de
numerix entreprises unis monteyne
spécialisée dans la transformation
digitale